bonjour je m'appelle dans lan et tam et
j'ai 18 ans je rêvais saint joseph et
ont pas tous michel entreprise de
l'offre d'habitat babis harris est une
entreprise basée dans l'ain port de
vêtements venus de l'ain donc des tarés
traditionnel des pendjabi des tuniques
et nous ce qu'on fait bien voilà c'est
de l'argent tu l'entreprise d'avis
arrêté en cours d'évolution c'est à dire
que on compte créer peut-être un magasin
mais surtout comme nous au marché avec
le commerce ambulant donc on veut
vraiment s'exprime partout sur l'île de
la réunion et une montée de nouveaux
projets par exemple avec des
organisations de mariage puis
actuellement nos entreprises on n'a pas
de salariés on n'a que des commerciaux
indépendants c'est-à-dire qu'ils
travaillent pour nous un
commissionnement pour l'année 2015 on
recherche des commerciaux
ça sera d'abord à titre indépendant mais
qui se
on dirait qu il y aura des postes en cdi
nous on a commencé comme ça en tant
qu'indépendant on faisait du
porte-à-porte chez des personnes l'a
fait notre page facebook et donc je
pense que toute personne a sa chance des
chapeaux débuté en tant qu'indépendant
pour être
commencez à l'indépendant il faut quand
même avoir le scoop et il faut être à
l'écouté des personnes que tous avoir
conseillé sur vous êtes notre nos
commerciaux indépendants
vous pouvez faire ça de plusieurs
manières lycos il faut vraiment avoir le
pmi si vous faites du porte à porte
mais si comme nous vous ouvrez une page
professionnelle badis harry pour
présenter vos produits
c'est aussi très bien un commercial doit
avoir une bonne connaissance du produit
être capable de valoriser l'image de la
marque prendre en compte les attentes de
sa clientèle savoir fidéliser et
prospecter de nouveaux clients
on recherche plusieurs couturiers
tu as aussi si c'est possible surtout
blé pour pouvoir
emmener nos clients tout via el khil
poirot qu'elle puisse ça y est c'est
joli sur mesure et même fait assez et
autres vêtements comme on l'a dit sur
mesure et selon les goûts la pièce
aujourd'hui nous on aimerait vraiment
des couturiers qui connaissent le show
lee qui savent le faire bien sûr mesures
pour que quand la personne vente mais ça
passe bien et c'est parfait on demande
que dû le savoir faire du coup on se
déplacera à dire les personnes quand ces
personnes à ils viendront chez nous on
verra la qualité de leur travail déjà
beaucoup monté et sinon
on ne recherche pas de diplôme ou quoi
que ce soit parce que quand vous avez
dit
au début avec des personnes très motivés
et passionnés par ce qu'ils font
salutaris est une jeune entreprise on
est tous des personnes dynamiques et
motivés et les personnes qui
travailleront avec mots on aimerait
autant qu'ils sont aussi souriante
dynamique et motivée une couturière doit
savoir être l écoute faire preuve de
patience et de concentration être doté
d'un sens du toucher et d'un sens
artistique avoir le goût de la
perfection
le conseil
ça c'est d'abord mes pièces
très motivé
monsieur de passionnés